jetzt ist ein urteil gefallen das
gericht sagt johnny depp darf als
frauenschläger bezeichnet werden mehr
details zu kennt die chefin giannina
kirsch und dies bei mir im studio
hallo ich habe es gerade schon gesagt
das gericht sagt er darf frauenschläger
genannt werden wie es die begründung
also zunächst einmal muss man sagen das
war ja ein prozess der sich über mehrere
wochen zog drei waren es ungefähr und in
diesem prozess haben diverse zeugen
ausgesagt unter anderem seiner ex frau
amber heard und amber heard hat so das
gericht genug beweise vorgelegt die ja
eindeutig machen dass johnny depp ihr
gegenüber gewalttätig war und zwar laut
urteil was uns auch vorliegt soll er sie
seit 2013 insgesamt zwölfmal misshandelt
haben und deswegen ist der richter zu
dem entschluss gekommen nachdem alle
zeugenaussagen und alle auch
beweismittel die ja vorliegen hatte
abgelegt hat ist da zu dem urteil
gekommen dass johnny depp sehr wohl als
frauenschläger bezeichnet werden kann
du hast gerade die beweise angesprochen
welche beweise sind das denn konkret
ja man muss ja sagen noch mal vielleicht
dass man das einmal noch mal betont es
ging in diesem prozess ja nicht um einen
krieg zwischen amber heard und johnny
depp in erster linie sondern eigentlich
war es einen verleumdungsprozess johnny
depp wollte verhindern dass dies anderes
schreibt aber dadurch dass amber heard a
aufgetreten ist als zeugen und so viel
aus der ehe in diesem gerichtssaal
getragen hat hat sich das natürlich zu
einer wahnsinnigen schlammschlacht
zwischen den beiden entwickelt und amber
heard hat mehrere sachen erzählt ja zum
beispiel erzählt dass er sie mit 30
flaschen beworfen haben soll
bei diesen würfen soll er sich angeblich
dabei die fingerkuppe abgeschnitten
haben
denn sei ja ständig betrunken gewesen
habe sie gewürgt habe sie misshandelt
sie sprach davon dass sie todesangst
hatte sie sind nannte ist wie eine art
geiselhaft in der sie sie sich gefunden
hat und er wiederum nannte sie
eine soziopathen die angeblich aus
scherz man darf es gar nicht sagen
ins ehebett geklappt hat also da kam so
viel schmutz ans licht zwischen den
beiden
das darf man vieles davon darf man
eigentlich gar nicht laut sagen es gab
auch ein video wie johnny depp wüst um
sich schlägt und ein ganzes hotel zimmer
demoliert und dieses video davon wurde
unter anderem auch in dem prozess als
beweismaterial so bürgern eingebracht
und was bedeutet das jetzt für johnny
depp konkret wenn man natürlich auch
schon sagt man darf ihn frauenschläger
nennen da es dafür beweise gibt wird
jetzt vielleicht ein strafprozess folgen
noch gibt es keinen strafprozess und
deswegen muss auch johnny depp jetzt
keine strafe zahlen denn johnny depp ist
der kläger er hat dies an verklagt und
wer damit durchgekommen
dann hätte er das recht auf
schadensersatz gehabt so ist es so dass
der prozess das urteil ist jetzt quasi
gesprochen worden jetzt kann johnny depp
in berufung gehen seine anwältin habt im
übrigen auch schon angekündigt dass sie
in berufung gehen wollen
was natürlich passieren kann ist dass
johnny depp wenn das urteil
rechtskräftig ist die kosten dieses
prozesses tragen muss und die
anwaltskosten das sind sicher ein paar
millionen aber johnny depp 200 millionen
schwer
das tut dem nicht so weh was ihm viel
mehr weh tut ist der ruf der jetzt
kaputt ist er war ein großer hollywood
star der jetzt frauenschläger genannt
werden darf ganz offiziell und das
verzeiht man nicht so richtig und eine
sache möchte ich noch sagen nach prozess
ist vor dem prozess denn johnny depp hat
ja in amerika zivilklage eingereicht
gegen amber heard wegen verleumdung und
hatte auch schon eine summe genannt die
er sich vorstellt und zwar ein
schadensersatz von 50 millionen euro
deswegen das urteil heute ist noch nicht
das ende des streits zwischen johnny
depp und amber heard mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bild schaut
euch hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren